hey youtubers is Charlie and in case you
did not already hear a copy of the flash
TV show the first episode of leaked
online so I'm not gonna allow anyone to
share it here in the comments or repost
the link or anything like that or post
spoilers but I am gonna talk about how
it happened and what the CW is gonna do
about it you know hit hit maybe post it
early on their website the same thing
happened to a bunch of Legend of Korra
book 3 episodes last week that was way
worse because it was like four episodes
instead of just one and they weren't
even the first four which means that
people watch them they missed out on a
giant chunk of this story so hello to
all the new people if you're just
finding me for the first time I do arrow
and flash videos every week be sure to
subscribe to get everything
once everything starts airing in the
fall like around October usually the
first week in October I'll just be doing
weekly videos for all the episodes so
it's gonna be a lot of fun and I'm
really excited for all those that are
wondering they're probably gonna start
airing season 3 of arrow and season one
of the flash around the same time arrow
season 2 started last year which was the
first week in October
so wTF is up with the lake well whatever
networks have brand-new shows that they
want critics to talk about they want to
create like a real positive buzz they
sent out DVD screeners they usually have
watermarks on them with some disclosure
language about not reselling or posting
them anywhere they're not meant for the
public The CW has been sending out
screeners of this first episode of the
flash so that is what leaked online one
of these DVD screeners it was either
posted by someone who had a screener or
someone stole it off of someone else's
desk and then posted that I actually
worked for a couple big news
organizations in real life I know
everyone always asked what I do in real
life
I actually do a lot of YouTube stuff for
big company trade websites so we get
piles and piles of screeners for
everything you've ever heard of and tons
of stuff that you would never ever want
to see so whenever you're mailing out
thousands and thousands of copies of
DVDs it's not hard to understand why
someone would steal one of those and
upload it to the Internet the other
possibility is that the CW intentionally
leaked the episode networks have done
that in the past is a way to drive
interest in something it usually only
works whenever it's like a comic book
thing or associated with a major fandom
like if a copy of Star Wars Episode
seven literally all of creation which is
flip the CW isn't really known for
licking their own material as a way to
generate viral interest and since the
flash TV show already has a ton of
really good buzz I don't
they would need to do that anyway so I
think that my first theory is the right
one someone stole a copy of the screener
and uploaded it to the Internet so what
does the CW gonna do about it
well typically networks whenever stuff
like this happens to defuse the
situation will just post that episode
whatever leaked online on their web site
whenever those Korra episodes leaked
though Nickelodeon decided to start
airing all the episodes on television
months in advance of their original
release date because it was only the
first episode of the flash to leak and
the CW just did upfront they're probably
not gonna start airing the episodes
early upfronts is typically where
networks make arrangements with
advertisers for them to buy advertising
at a certain time and place like on the
episodes of a television show so that's
all been scheduled far far in advance so
if the CW aired the flash early they
would be losing millions and millions of
dollars in advertising so everyone's
still gonna have to wait till October
for the season to start officially but
they still could totally post that full
episode on their website and just stream
it for free as a way to control the
situation so originally they were just
gonna air the episode at Comic Con and
then maybe post it online like a week
after that so they were gonna post it
online eventually if you were one of the
people who watched it please use spoiler
tags whenever you're talking about it in
the comments but if you've already read
any of the flash origin stories you
already know what the story is even
though they never do things exactly like
they do in the comics arrow for instance
changes a lot of character backstories
and has created a lot of new original
characters like Diggle but if you do
want to read a story that's very close
to the story they're gonna be telling on
the flash TV show you should read flash
rebirth it was written by Geoff Johns
one of the writers of the flash TV show
there are a lot of small differences but
the matically it's the same idea Geoff
Johns has actually been one of my
favorite DC Comics writers in the last
20 years oh and he's also executive
producer on the Batman vs Superman movie
right now he's actually writing the new
Superman comic that's being drawn by
John Romita Jr he's the guy that did
kick-ass which is why it looks very
similar a very kick-ass version of
Superman if you want to learn more about
their version of it I'm gonna be posting
a link in the description to this big
New York Times article about it but now
let's talk about some other new flash
footage because the CW has been posting
a ton of interviews and a ton of
additive like extra material about the
universe of the flashes in like what's
gonna be going on with STAR Labs and all
the metahumans that were created
whenever the particle accelerator
exploded you know aka the
I've actually been talking a lot about
this in my arrow videos this year so if
you're like a brand-new subscriber and
you just found me and you haven't seen
any my arrow stuff please let me know
I'll actually be adding a link in the
description I made like a ton of arrow
videos this year it was a lot of fun the
summer is actually one of the best times
to catch up on arrow so you have a
couple months before season three starts
even though there are two different
groups of people making these shows they
will exist in a shared universe we even
saw Stephen Amell in the flash trailer
so watching both these shows will
increase your enjoyment the fun thing
about the flash that's different from
arrow is that they're going full-on with
the superpowers if you've seen the
trailer you know that weather wizard is
the first rogue we meet I don't really
count zoom as a rogue they're definitely
not trying to hide him either
zoom or professor zoom or however you
want to think about him has been such a
huge part of the flash stories for such
a long time that there would be no point
in trying to hide him anyway even though
Edward Thawne is working at the same
police station as Barry they're not
really saying he's zoom so he will be
present at all times like an overarching
story while week to week Barry tracks
down rogues and other metahumans but
they're not officially going to confirm
him probably till the end of the season
so one of the other big changes they
made is the Harrison Wells character in
the Canon the founder of STAR Labs is
named garrison slate that character is
featured in a lot of Blue Beetle comics
and because arrows introducing Blue
Beetle is here we might get to see some
STAR Labs Kord industries overlap Blue
Beetle hasn't officially been confirmed
by the CW but they did put out a casting
call for season three using the golden
age name of the Blue Beetle so it's a
bit of a dead giveaway
whenever arrows does bring them on just
like Barry Allen I'd expect the Ted Kord
character to be like pre Blue Beetle or
it'll be like Batman year one where he's
still figuring things out so there's a
really big easter egg that people are
talking about in relation to the flash
pilot but it's kind of spoilery so just
skip forward in the video like 25
seconds if you'd want to know anything
about it everybody ready so here we go
it's all about Gorilla Grodd it sounds
like the flash is gonna do a Planet of
the Apes situation whereby Gorilla Grodd
attains his super intelligence through
the same dimensional rift that was
caused by the particle accelerator I
don't expect him to come on the show
anytime soon but don't be surprised if
you see more references to him aside
from zoom in the rows Gorilla Grodd is
like one of the most infamous flash
villains which is kind of funny because
Ryze is the plan of the Apes is coming
out really soon so because of VidCon
this week my schedule is a little weird
but I'm still going to try and post
a bonus err video before I go so I'm
also doing that special personal Q&A so
feel free to ask me any personal
questions you want in addition to arrow
and flash stuff and remember if you have
seen that leaked flash footage please
use spoiler tags if you're gonna comment
about it but right now click here to
learn all about Blue Beetle and the
other Batman characters that are coming
to arrow season 3 and it's gonna be a
lot of fun and click here to get my
breakdown to the flash trailer thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow
vice
you